congratulations to you do you see
yourself as a trailblazer I I mean like
I set out there if you had told my
ten-year-old self that I'd be winning an
award as a dancer as a trailblazer I
wouldn't have believed you like it was
all I dreamed of did I eat sleep breathe
dance so no I'm so grateful the happiest
path it's so cold what is your little
mini-me does she think you're a
trailblazer or does she just think
you're like go to bed and you know no
she's like mom's mom and mom is so
uncool she started rolling her eyes at
things I say I was like all right I
thought I had told 13 like I didn't
think that was gonna happen at 6:00 yeah
no no I am so uncool she loves me
obviously but I'm uncool for sure you're
cool because you you stepped in for
Kelly Ripa and you were fabulous every
time you hop do that talk thing is there
a Jenna Dewan talk show in your future
would you do it I you know I I really
love it I have to say like I love I met
Kelly go have more vacations
I have so much fun filling in for you
it's a blast and yeah maybe
Never Say Never I would totally be open
Olivia newton-john is being honored
tonight what has she meant to your
careers and inspiration and how
wonderful to honor her tonight oh I love
her so much and just like her whole
career and the first time I saw Greece
it blew my mind and I'm matter for the
first time tonight and she is very cool
and very grounded and you know they sing
don't meet your idols but I was very
happy to meet her and go that's what I
wanted you know she's amazing
and you're I mean you're so busy it's
just insane to me that you even have
like a you're pulled together to a new
Netflix show can you explain the premise
a little bit for our fans it's a musical
drama so a 10-episode series coming out
Netflix and it's every episode is its
own self-contained love story musicals
so their song their stands there's
acting
it's it's really unique I don't think
you'll ever see anything like it that's
cool something I could get into though
um and Broadway baby how was our
Broadway um uh my Broadway baby he's
amazing did he come tonight no he didn't
make it tonight he's working he's busy
helping you at all with this show cuz he
was a Tony winner on bright well I know
you know what yeah he did he did give me
some little tips and hints there cuz it
was my first you know musical experience
so yeah he's very helpful things are
good things are great
[Music]